I know I must have said it a thousand times
if I've said it once. But you have two copies of
every chromosome. One from Mom and one from Dad. I
find it easier to understand where my chromosomes come from if
I color them pink, say, for the ones that came
from Mom, and blue for the ones that came from Dad.
But let's not forget that your Mom and your Dad
also had chromosomes from their parents, the maternal and paternal lines
of their own, your maternal grandma and grandpa, and your
paternal grandma and grandpa. And we could keep drawing this farther
and farther back in time. But if you like to
think about it, you're a mix of your grandparents as much
as you are your parents. If we just look over
here on your Mom's side, she had a whole set of
chromosomes from her mother and a whole set of chromosomes from
her father. And she didn't just pass down a whole complete
chromosome set from one of her parents
to you. When her germ cells underwent meiosis,
her chromosomes actually crossed over. This had
the effect of mixing and matching her own
parents chromosomes, your grandparent's chromosomes. So that when she passed
these chromosomes onto you, you'll notice that your maternal chromosomes are
actually a mix of your grandparents' chromosomes, recombination is
what allows you to actually have chromosomes that are
mixes and matches of your grandparents'. Now we can go
back in time to your great grandparents and we
could have an even finer resolution map with four colors
instead of two or your great great grandparents and
do eight colors instead of four. And let's not forget
about your Dad over here, either. Your paternal chromosomes came
from your father, who had a mother and father himself.
And his own maternal and paternal chromosomes underwent chromosome
recombination. And the result is a mix and match
of your Dad's parents' chromosomes. And then he passed
one set of those chromosomes on to you. So
you're also a mix of your paternal grandparents as
well. So based on recombination in these inheritance patterns
from your parents and grandparents, how much DNA identity
do you share with any given grandparent? Go ahead and
pick which answer you think is best.